A blink and you'll miss it "Black Panther"-related
cameo in "Thor 4" could have massive story
ramifications for Phase 4 of the MCU.
Keep watching for the major Black Panther
cameo you probably missed in "Thor: Love and Thunder."
Warning! Spoilers ahead.
"Thor: Love and Thunder" is out in theaters
now, and the titular hero is up against a
new foe.
Gorr the God Butcher is on a mission to kill
all gods across the universe, a ruthless rampage
that leads him to the shores of New Asgard.
While Gorr's actions threaten to usher in
a new age of chaos, Thor is faced with the
return of his ex-girlfriend, Dr. Jane Foster,
who now bears the mantle of "The Mighty Thor."
It's a complicated time for the God of Thunder.
"Jane?!"
One of the film's core strengths is that it
explores the mysterious lives of the gods
and goddesses that populate the mythologies
of various cultures.
Although we've seen Norse gods like Odin,
Loki, and Frigga, the latest "Thor" franchise
installment introduces viewers to a variety
of deities in Omnipotent City, a gilded temple
where gods can partake in heavenly debauchery
away from the woes of mankind.
The star-studded lineup of deities is key
to the plot, but also provides the opportunity
for levity within a narrative that's as serious
as it is silly.
Some of the faces of the gods are more recognizable
than others, including one figure who should
be familiar to fans of the MCU.
With Gorr in possession of the Necrosword,
our heroes know that they'll need to raise
a formidable army to defeat him and ensure
the safe return of Asgard's youth.
To accomplish that goal, Thor, Jane, Valkyrie,
and Korg hitch up a converted amusement park
ride and head to Omnipotent City.
While Thor tries to iron out a deal with the
inevitably pompous Zeus, viewers are privy
to a glimpse at the gods and goddesses assembled,
including the exceedingly adorable God of Dumplings.
However, there's an even more interesting
idol in attendance: The panther goddess Bast,
whose lore is extremely important to the "Black
Panther'' franchise.
Although Bast only appears in flashback as
a shadowy feline figure in the 2018 solo film
starring Chadwick Boseman, viewers finally
get to see the goddess in full physical form
in "Thor: Love and Thunder."
Played by actress and singer Akosia Sabet,
Bast returns to the MCU for the first time
since her premiere appearance.
Knowing Kevin Feige's proclivity for Easter
eggs and callbacks, it's unlikely to be her last.
"You never forget your first."
Her visage isn't as bombastic as some of the
deities seated around her, but her cat-eared
helmet and golden adornments still draw the
eye.
Her appearance is brief, but her presence
cements director Taika Waititi's attention
to detail.
Even though Thor is off-Earth going on his
own adventures, the moment reminds viewers
that the events of the film correlate to a
larger narrative.
Within the Marvel canon, the panther goddess
has been worshiped since around 10,000 BC.
Bast is an African deity that can take a male
or female form.
As the source of the magic that imbues the
Black Panther with their powers, Bast is revered
in Wakanda.
In the comics, the late King T'Challa's sister
Shuri takes the opportunity to stand before
Bast, though she is deemed too immature to
become the next Black Panther.
However, Shuri does eventually take up the
mantle and become queen of Wakanda, a journey
that could be utilized for the upcoming film
adaptation.
Whether or not "Wakanda Forever" makes use
of that particular storyline, it makes sense
that the panther goddess would play some kind
of role in the narrative.
Bast's existence in Omnipotent City could
also hint at what's to come in Phase Four.
The goddess also has ties to Victor von Doom,
who will ultimately become Dr. Doom, and Reed
Richards, whose appearance in "Doctor Strange
in the Multiverse of Madness" could be teasing
a classic Marvel Comics storyline called "Secret
Wars."
Bast is also the half-sibling to the god Khonshu
from "Moon Knight," a connection that provides
an opportunity for Marvel to flesh out the
minor characters it's introduced over the years.
Whatever it means for the big picture, Bast's
appearance is a fun detail to look out for
whenever you catch "Thor: Love and Thunder."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about "Thor:
Love and Thunder" are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.